good morning john this week i saw a
tweet from the new york times being
shouted about on twitter it states an
organic cotton tote needs to be used 20
000 times to offset the overall impact
of production according to a 2018 study
that equates to daily use for 54 years
having seen people shout about this i
quote tweeted the article and said i
didn't know why people were upset would
they rather not know it all and some
people were like yeah i kind of i kind
of would rather not know it all and i
get this but i'd like to make the case
that we kind of have two options we can
either not care which like i get it or
we have to pay attention and care based
on reality the fact that a cotton tote
bag might have a larger environmental
impact than 50 000 plastic bags it seems
like a piece of information i should
have accessed is it entirely accurate
maybe because i think that this study
was based on like a really big heavy
cotton tote that like had really thick
thick cotton and a tote that uses less
cotton it's gonna have less impact
though it also will maybe have a less
long lifespan this stuff is complicated
but it is important to know that just
because something is made out of cotton
or organic cotton doesn't make it good
for the environment it's resource
intensive to grow crops if we think
cotton is always good because it's all
natural or whatever we start putting
everything in cotton bags and and we
start using cotton like it's disposable
this has happened to me i've gotten
shoes and they gave them to me in a box
inside a cotton bag there was already a
box extra packaging can convey a sense
of like high quality of care for the
customer and of eco-friendliness that
all have nothing to do with the product
or reality so yeah this is a thing that
i think people should know about this
actually but the basics if you want to
know what you should do there are
reusable totes that have a lot less
impact on the environment than cotton
particularly like the really strong
vinyl ones they're like the fabric that
a tent is made out of and those are the
best option unless if you already have a
tote the totes you have are the greenest
option they're already in your home or
you can go to a secondhand shop or a
thrift store where there will be
probably bags there that you can buy
that were otherwise destined for a
landfill so that's the answer to that
question but the broader more
interesting question is like where do i
draw the line between the stuff that i
care about and the stuff that i don't
and for me i draw the line at the stuff
that like i'm caring about it's clear
that if you are sort of upset by this
article you probably have some cotton
totes like that's the reason that you
like that's the visceral reason that we
got defensive right like i have a bunch
and we got those because we cared or
because they were swag at a conference
my point is a lot of people don't have
the space to care about this stuff and i
totally understand that but if we cared
enough to like imagine that a cotton
tote was eco-friendly then we should
change our mind when presented evidence
to the contrary if we're gonna care we
have to orient our care based on reality
now is that easy no no it's complicated
it also involves understanding that lots
of things
aren't really about me or you or us
which i get it is a kind of un-american
idea we think everything is about us but
like ocean plastic is a great example
here like people think i need to use a
reusable bag because of ocean plastic
like my bag might end up in the ocean no
like you should use a reusable bag
because just making things to throw them
away is a bad idea like there are better
ways to do but ocean plastic is like 50
fishing equipment and almost all of the
rest of it comes from places that don't
have good robust waste management
systems like we do in the us and
thinking that like a reusable tote is a
fix for that problem ignores the fact
that the fix for that problem is
international it involves a lot of
people who we do not have direct control
over it's a bit of a bummer but it's a
really good thing to know and these
things in general aren't that hard to
find out they just require us to look at
how we're sort of feeling vaguely about
the vibe of a thing
passed that into a little bit of reality
like are we being sold an idea because
somebody's trying to sell us something
or is this actually gonna have a
positive impact some of what we find
they're going to be a little complicated
yeah but like simplicity is almost
always a lie so seems right to me john
i'll see you on tuesday